[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Today we're going
to move on to another topic I've
kept hinting at all semester,
but it's finally here.
Which is to think
more explicitly
about equity, or fairness.
So our discussions this semester
have been almost solely couched
in language of efficiency.
We talk about maximizing
social welfare,
we talk about the total size of
the triangle and the squares.
But we don't actually
talk about who gets what.
We very much stayed away
from equity concerns
and focused just on
efficiency concerns.
The problem is, that doesn't
lead us very far in life,
because you can have
many outcomes that
are equally efficient, but have
different equity consequences.
The best example, of course,
is perfect competition
versus a perfectly priced
discriminating monopolist.
Remember, under
perfect competition,
you maximize welfare.
But a perfectly priced
discriminating monopolist
also maximizes welfare.
The difference is,
in the latter case,
the monopolist gets all the
surplus, when the former case,
it's shared between
producers and consumers.
So it's sort of
weird to say we're
indifferent between those two
outcomes-- to one where Apple
gets all our money,
and one where
Apple gets some of our money
and we get some of our money.
Seems strange to say
we're indifferent
between those outcomes.
So now, in subsets,
that's the easy case.
So we're talking about
equity efficiency.
In some sense, the
easy case is the case
where there's two equally
efficient outcomes,
and they have different
equity consequences.
That's a rare case.
The more common case is what
we call the equity efficiency
trade-off.
Which is that by making
distributions more equal,
we are going to
induce inefficiencies.
That the act of making
distribution more equal
is going to introduce
inefficiencies in the system.
And that's where things
get really interesting.
OK?
So in other words-- so the
best way to think about this,
I find most helpful, is due
to a famous economist named
Arthur Okun, and his thought
example of the leaky bucket.
Okun's thought example was
the following-- imagine
that the way the government
distributed money
from the rich the
poor was literally
they went to the rich, had the
rich put money in a bucket,
and they carried it and dumped
out in front of the poor.
Imagine that's the way
distribution happened.
Well, in that
world, if I told you
that every dollar a rich
person put in the bucket got
carried along and got
handed to a poor person--
so Bill Gates' dollar became
a homeless guy's dollar--
probably most of us
would think that was OK.
I think the vast
majority of Americans
would say, yeah,
probably the homeless guy
could use $1 more
than Bill Gates could.
But now, imagine that there
was a leak in the bucket.
Imagine Bill Gates
put 100 pennies in,
but along the way to the
poor person it leaked out,
and so we dumped it in
front of the poor person,
it was less than 100.
Now, then the question
is, how much leakage?
Well, if the leakage was
one penny out of 100,
you probably wouldn't
change your mind.
Would it change your mind if
it was 20 pennies out of 100?
50 pennies out of 100?
What if it was 100
pennies out of 100?
What if taking $1
from Bill Gates,
by the time it got to the
poor person, it was all gone?
At what point would
you say, you know what?
I don't think that's
a good idea anymore.
And really, that's a great way
of thinking about the equity
efficiency trade-off--
how much efficiency
are you willing to give up to
redistribute from rich to poor?
And the efficiency you
give up is represented
by the leakage in the bucket.
Now, what we're
going to do with this
in this lecture and
next Monday's lecture,
is we're going to discuss
this equity efficiency
trade-off in four steps.
The first step is going to
be talking about valuation--
that is taking the difficult
step we've already taken so far
and asking, how does society
feel about some people
versus other people?
So far, we've just thought
of one generic person,
and they're represented
by total surplus.
But in fact, we have a
distribution of people,
and how do economists think
about taking money away
from person A and
giving to person B.
That's a new topic for us.
The second thing we're
going to talk about
is what do we know about
the facts on inequality?
What do we know
about what's actually
happened to the distribution
of resources in the US
at a point in time,
and over time?
The third thing is,
we're going to talk
about the sources of leakage.
That is, why does the
bucket leak in practice?
Why do we typically think
there is an equity efficiency
trade-off?
Why can't we just take the
dollar from the rich guy
and give it to the poor guy?
What caused the leakage?
And then finally, we're going
to talk about some examples
of transfer mechanisms.
We're going to talk
about what society
does in practice to
transfer from rich to poor
and how it works, and what the
ultimate leakage looks like.
So that's going to be our
goal in the next two lectures.
It's going to be think
about this equity efficiency
trade-off.
So to start that goal, we have
to start with this first issue
of choosing the social optimum.
That is, how do we
evaluate transfers
from one party to another party?
And so to rank outcomes,
what we're going to do is use
the same thing we always do
when we want to think about
trade-offs--
which is, we're going to do
a constrained maximization
exercise.
When I want to think about
your trade-off between cookies
and pizza, I did a
constrained optimization
of your utility functions,
subject to your budget
constraint.
When, now I want to think
about your trade-off between me
and Patricia, now instead, we're
going to a different utility
function.
In fact, we're going to use
what we call a social welfare
function.
A social welfare
function basically
society's utility function.
How does society value
different individuals?
So loosely speaking,
social welfare function
is some function of utility
of person 1, common utility
of person 2, common, dot, dot,
dot, comma utility of person
350 million, if it's the US.
So it's some
aggregation function.
Just like we mathematically
aggregate your taste
for pizza and cookies.
Now we're going to
mathematically aggregate
all society's utility to get
a social welfare function.
So for example,
consider figure 21-1.
Let's think of society as only
two people, Homer and Ned--
let's imagine that's all of
society, because once again,
it's always these two by
two examples are easy.
What we've drawn here are
what's called isowelfare curves.
What these are, are basically
society's indifference curves.
Just like if these x and
y-axis are pizza and cookies,
I would draw a difference curve
between pizza and cookies.
Now drawing society
as a difference curve
between Homer and Ned.
So in other words,
what this says
is that society's indifferent
between Homer having U1 super
H, and Ned having U1 super
N, versus the Homer having
U2 two super H and
Ned having U2 super N.
Those are combinations
of resources across which
society is indifferent.
And much like any other
indifference curve,
further out is better.
We'd all prefer both Homer
and Ned to have more--
more is better.
So that's easy-- the further
out the isowelfare curve goes,
the happier you are.
And a long isowelfare
curve are allocations
of resource across individuals
among which we're indifferent.
Now, the question is, that's
all well and easy to graph
as a theoretical proposition.
But in practice, what does
a social welfare function
look like?
Utility functions, I just
wrote down a usually function,
and you took it as--
I wrote down square root,
we worked with that.
But there were some
properties we wrote down
that gave us a sense of what
utility functions look like.
Social welfare functions
are much more open,
because they don't
come from introspection
about your preferences.
They come from introspection
about society's preferences,
which are much harder.
So what we do here is we
talk about some typical forms
of social welfare functions
that we use in economics.
The most common form
is what's called
utilitarian social
welfare function--
welfare function.
This is due to the
philosopher Jeremy Bentham--
if you ever visit
University College London--
actually, if you did until
about 15 years ago, you
could see Jeremy Bentham's
head, it was on display.
He was a famous
philosopher there.
But apparently, students would
take it out, use it for soccer.
So they took it off display,
you can't see it anymore.
But he's a famous
philosopher, and he came up
with the idea of utilitarianism.
And basically utilitarianism
is, it simply says,
the social welfare function is
simply the linear aggregation
of every individual's utility.
So social welfare
function is simply,
U1 plus U2 plus U3 plus--
plus U 350 million.
So the US social
welfare function
is literally, we just measure
everyone's utility, add it up,
and that's the social
welfare function.
And in subsets, it's a
natural starting point.
Right, you just say,
look, it's just a linear--
it's like having a
linear utility function.
It's a linear utility function.
Now, let's be clear--
what this says is that
I don't care any more
about anybody in society.
So I don't care any more
or less about Bill Gates
and the homeless guy.
I treat them--
I'm indifferent between them.
But does this mean
I wouldn't want
to transfer money from Bill
Gates the homeless guy?
In fact, I still would want
to transfer-- and why--
depending on the leakage.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Because of the
condition of [INAUDIBLE]..
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah, exactly.
I care about the
utility the same,
but the next dollar's not
worth anything to Bill Gates.
It's worth a lot to
the homeless guy.
So a utilitarian social
welfare function,
which is a natural
starting point--
I don't think it's
particularly liberal, it's
a natural starting point,
you're just adding them up--
ends up with a very, in
substance, redistributive
conclusion, which
is that you want
to attribute from rich to poor.
Indeed, what the optimum with
utilitarian social welfare
function is that you
want to redistribute
until marginal
utilities are equal.
So this social function
calls for fairly radical
redistribution.
This says, you want
to redistribute
until utilities are equal.
Marginal utilities
are equal, I'm sorry.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
is constant [INAUDIBLE]..
JONATHAN GRUBER: Well,
once again, you're right,
I mean, you just add
people and subtract people.
Wouldn't be a problem.
But for now, let's just
assume the copulation
is because you've got
one given society.
OK, so if two people,
it's just Ned and Homer,
just add them up.
All it says is, as Ned is
more resources than Homer,
we're going redistribute.
Indeed, with this function,
if we make the assumption
that total social
resources are fixed,
that society has a fixed budget
constraint that can't change,
then what does
this function imply
would be the optimal
distribution of income?
So ignoring the fact that people
might work less or more hard--
ignore that, imagine it's
just the total amount of money
a society has.
If that's your social
welfare function,
what's the optimal
distribution of income?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are we assuming that
makes everyone equally happy?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yes, everyone--
good point, fixed resources are
identical utility functions.
Great point.
Yeah, exactly, great catch.
If it's a fixed
bundle of income,
and everyone has identical
utility functions,
then we simply want everyone to
have the same amount of money.
Why?
Because giving someone $1
would make them less happy
than taking away from someone
else would make them sad.
It's all about diminishing
margin of utility--
just like we talked
about last time.
So now, that might not
be true, for example--
does anybody know who
Scrooge McDuck is?
Scrooge McDuck?
Raise your hand if you
know Scrooge McDuck.
OK, not bad.
Scrooge McDuck is
this comic character
from when I was a kid
who used to like to dive
and swim in his money.
Now, he clearly
had a higher margin
of utility of the
next dollar than I do.
OK, so if Scrooge McDuck
really likes money,
we might want to let Scrooge
McDuck have some extra money.
But if utility
functions are identical,
and social resources are fixed,
this is one equal distribution
income.
That's really radical.
That's beyond what any
country in the world does--
a perfect equal
distribution of income.
But it comes naturally out
of this fairly plain vanilla
social welfare function.
Quite a striking finding, right?
Now, but in fact,
if we think of this
as sort of our starting point--
Bentham was actually
conservative,
this is typically viewed as a
conservative starting point,
even though it has a
very liberal conclusion.
The more liberal
extreme is what we
call a Rawlsian social welfare
function, due to philosopher
James, I think, Rawls,
who was at Harvard--
Philip John Rawls, I'm sorry.
He said the goal of society
is to maximize the well-being
of its worst-off member.
So Rawlsian social
welfare function
is the minimum of U1 comma
U2 comma dot, dot, dot.
In other words,
all you care about
is the worst-off
person in society.
OK, so Rawlsian social
welfare function would say,
all we care about is the
worst-off person in society.
Now, unless you
think this is crazy,
let's think about where
Rawls came at this from.
Rawls came at this
from the concept
that he called the
veil of ignorance.
Which he said, look,
before you were born,
you know nothing about
what you're going to be.
You could be born to rich
or poor, healthy, sick,
you have no idea.
You're just a little embryo.
From that perspective,
he said, what
you would want is to make sure
that you're going to be OK.
And so from that
perspective, society
should want to
minimize the well-being
of the worst-off member.
That was his rationalization.
But this has really
radical implications.
Not only does this say, we
want an equal distribution
of income, this says,
we would destroy
any amount of money of the rich
to give some money to the poor.
So imagine what this
says, if I could take--
if everyone's distribution of
income was equal in this class,
let's say our society,
except Patricia
has $40,000 more than everyone
else, then what that would say
is, we would happily take
$40,000 away from Patricia
and give $1 to me.
Because I'm, like everyone
else, the worst-off member.
But let's say I'm $1 less than
the rest of you, make it easy.
So you all the same amount
of money, I have $1 less,
she has $40,000 more.
Rawlsian would say,
we'd happily take away
her $40,000 to give me $1.
It doesn't make a
whole lot of sense.
But it's one sort of
extreme, and it's basically
this notion of--
it's in some sense, Rawlsian.
Think of an extremely
risk-averse embryo,
gives you the Rawlsian.
The idea that, I don't know
what my income is going to be,
but I want to make
sure I'm not poor.
Then I would want sort of
a Rawlsian social welfare
function.
So that's sort of
a liberal extreme.
Now, there's two
other views, which
are harder to write
down mathematically--
at least in the context of
1401, but are important.
Let's take the most
conservative extreme.
So if Rawlsian is the
most liberal extreme,
the most conservative
extreme would be the Nozick--
Nozickian argument-- it's not
really social welfare function.
His argument is that we should
never redistribute income.
We should only
redistribute opportunities.
In other words, once everyone
has equal opportunities,
then we just roll
the dice and let
things lay in where they may.
So here's an example.
Let's say all of us are born
with the same opportunities
in life, and we end
up where we are today.
And let's say that you
guys are willing to pay me
$10 every lecture
to hear me lecture.
Well, if that's true, at
the end of the semester.
I have a lot more
money than you.
Nozick would say,
well, why should I
be taxed and given to you?
That makes no sense.
You voluntarily payed me.
Why should LeBron James, we're
voluntarily paying to see him
play, why should he then
be taxed on the money we
voluntarily gave him?
So Nozick's views,
as long as we all
start with the equality of
opportunity, let the dice roll.
If someone has more
talents and skills,
and people want to pay
them, then let them keep it.
So basically, Nozick's idea
is to essentially equalize
opportunity, and letting the
dice land where they may.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is this
just like opportunity
that can be regulated?
Or is it-- I was
thinking that [INAUDIBLE]
might mean like [INAUDIBLE]
doesn't have equal opportunity.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Right.
So there's two problems
with the Nozickian view.
One is, what is opportunity?
What is equal opportunity mean?
And the answer is, it's
not clear-- there's
genetic equal opportunity.
There's the fact that
if I'm born in poverty,
I go to lower quality
schools, so I don't really
have an equal opportunity.
I went to a ritzy public
high school in New Jersey,
because my parents
were well-off.
Like someone who went to high
school in some poor town of New
Jersey didn't have the
same opportunities I did.
So the first problem with this
argument is that, in some sense
it's impossible to
equalize opportunity.
And so it starts
with a false premise.
The second problem with this
argument is it ignores luck.
It ignores luck.
Which is that in fact, if you
look at why some people are
rich and some people are poor,
even with equal opportunities,
a lot of it's not skill
or talent, it's luck.
They were in the right
place at the right time,
had the right parents who gave
them the right inheritance.
They met the right
person in business school
and that person brought
them into their company.
It's luck.
Indeed, if you try to
explain differences in income
by any measure of skill we have,
you can never explain even half
of the difference in
income across people.
A lot of it appears to be luck.
Well, in that case,
we would then not
want to let lucky people be
richer than unlucky people.
That doesn't really
seem to make sense.
So I want skilled people
richer than unskilled people,
but it seems like we
might redistribute
against from the
lucky to the unlucky.
So that's the other problem
with the Nozickian notion.
And then finally, the fourth
approach, the fourth approach
is a totally alternative
view, which we
call commodity egalitarianism.
Commodity egalitarianism.
This view is simply
saying, look,
who cares how much money
I have relative to you?
All that matters, that you
can live a decent life.
So this says is
what matters is not
relative income but
absolute resources.
What matters is making
sure everyone in society
has food and
shelter, and I would
argue health care, et cetera.
A set of base things
everyone should have.
And then above that, who cares?
So in substance,
commodity egalitarianism
is a mix of Rawls and Nozick.
It cares about the
minimum, saying
we've got to make
sure everyone has
a decent standard of living.
But above that,
let's roll the dice.
As long as we're providing
a decent standard of living
for everyone, that if someone
can make a lot of money,
let's let them.
So this is a very
interesting view.
And it basically talks
about the view of
should we give people
money or stuff?
In the sense of commodity
egalitarianism view,
says, look, let's
worry less about money
and more about stuff.
Let's make sure everybody
has enough stuff
to live a decent life.
And then we'll roll
the dice from there.
So let me start--
if I was not clear enough at
all, none of these are right.
These are all alternative views.
It is harder to
write down to make
an assumption about
social welfare function
than it is about a
utility function.
We have less
parameters to draw on.
But the point is, these are
all different ways of thinking
about the trade-off.
We can't avoid thinking
That's why, once again,
we're the dismal science--
because nothing's free.
We can't avoid thinking
about the trade-off.
We have to think
about redistribution.
And these give us
different frameworks
for thinking about that.
Questions about that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What-- for the
Nozickian and the other one,
what happens if there are
individuals that just don't--
they always make
the wrong decision.
They'll spend all their
money irresponsibly,
and therefore, they can't
have a producing [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Well, I mean, that's
a very interesting question.
So I think Nozick--
I mean, I don't know, I don't
know how hard-hearted a guy
Nozick is--
but if you took the Nozickian
view to the extreme,
as long as that person had
an equal opportunity, then
they should just die.
You know, they had
an equal opportunity,
if they made a series of bad
decisions, why should we care?
Now, that's obviously
an extreme view,
but I think that would
be the view there.
Whereas, commodity
egalitarianism would say, look,
let's at least make sure that,
despite their bad decisions,
they don't starve.
But we don't want to
make them rich if they're
making bad decisions.
So let's just set a minimum
and get them to that,
and then let things
go from there.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is that where the
idea of basic income comes from?
JONATHAN GRUBER: That's
a great segue to what
I want to talk about next.
Which is, let's
actually talk about--
turn these into practice,
and measuring inequality.
And I'm going to back to
your basic income point
in a couple of minutes.
So let's talk about actually
measuring inequality.
And the reason
we're going to talk
about this, because
it highlights
how important this issue is.
So let's go to
some facts-- these
are from my textbook from 1441.
So go to Figure 21-2.
Ignore the last row for second,
focus on the first five rows.
What the first five
rows show is the percent
of income received by each
quintile, or each fifth,
of the income distribution.
In other words, each
row is 20% of people.
So the first row is the
poorest 20% of people,
the next row is the second
and so on.
The numbers in each
cell are the share
of income held by that quintile.
In other words, if the
distribution of income
was totally equal, every one
of these numbers would be 20.
If distribution of
income was totally equal,
every quintile would have 20.
But in fact, that's never
been true in any society
ever in history--
the richest always have
more than the poorest.
We have no perfect
distribution of income.
And you see that if
you look at in 1967,
when these data first
are reliably collected,
you see that the highest
20% of individuals
had about 10 times as
much as the lowest 20%.
That there was a
lot of inequality.
Now, if you roll
forward till about 1980,
that gap was shrinking.
So you saw that the highest
20% share was about fixed,
but the lowest 20% was rising.
But then, if you
look since 1980,
that gap has widened enormously.
To the point now
where the 2013 is
the latest here, but the
facts haven't really changed--
the richest 20% of Americans
earn more than half the income
in America.
And the poorest 20%
earn only about 3%
of the income in America.
So inequality has widened
massively in the US.
How does that put us
in international terms?
And I'm sorry, and the last row
was the share of the top 5%--
this is particular striking.
In fact, go to the
next page-- this
is a graph of the share
of the top 1% of income
holders in America.
So this is the share of
income held by the 1% richest
Americans.
You can see that in the
early 20th century, that
was pretty high, almost 20%.
It then fell down about
10% by the early 1970s.
It's now up-- and by the
latest date, up to about 25%.
It's higher than it was at
the beginning of 20th century.
So the 1% of richest
Americans have about 25%
of the income earned in society.
So it's extremely unequal
income distribution.
Once again, not
saying bad or good--
I'm making a positive statement.
Unequal is irrefutable.
Bad or good, we'll get to.
But it's irrefutable a very
unequal income distribution.
It's also irrefutable, we have
a much more unequal distribution
of income than the
rest of the world.
So Figure 21-4, we compare
the facts for the US
to the rest of
the OECD, which is
a set of developed economies.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is this before
or after income tax?
JONATHAN GRUBER:
That's a great point.
This all before tax, before tax.
But if anything,
if you add taxes,
it makes us look even worse
relative to other countries,
because our tax are
less progressive
than other countries.
This is before tax
and before transfers.
So if you look at other--
so this list is
a lot of numbers.
Look at the bottom line.
The bottom line is the average
across all non-US countries
of the share of income held
by each part of the income
distribution.
And the next to bottom line,
and the bottom line is the US.
So we say the bottom 10%
of income distribution,
on average across these
countries, has 3% of income.
Indeed, nowhere
except for Mexico
is the number lower
than the 1.6% in the US.
Likewise, you look at the
top 10% of income earners,
on average across
these countries,
they earn 25% of the income.
In the US, it's 30%.
And indeed, nowhere is the
number higher than in--
except in Mexico and Turkey.
So we are the most unequal
country, except for Mexico,
on this list.
Once again, not saying good
or bad, just saying the facts.
We're going to come to how
we think about good or bad.
So those are the facts
about inequality.
But as the question
here pointed out,
it's not clear we
care about inequality.
Indeed, in a standard
economic framework,
I don't care about inequality.
My utility is a function
of my consumption, not
your consumption.
Sustainable economic framework,
I don't care about inequality,
I just care about what I have.
And that speaks more to the
commodity egalitarianism view.
Which is, how are we doing in
making sure people have enough
to live?
And to do that, we
say, we move from--
so when we talk
about inequality,
inequality is a measure
of relative distribution.
Want to move to something which
is the measure of absolute--
absolute income, and that's
what we call the poverty line.
The poverty line in
the US is a measure
of absolute deprivation--
what share of Americans are
earning less than some minimum
standard they need to live?
Now, you can immediately
see the problem.
With inequality, it's
unit free, right?
I simply compare
dollars to dollars.
Once I start going here, I
have to make a judgment, which
is, what is deprivation?
What do you need to live?
So in substance, this
makes more sense--
absolutely makes more
sense, in substance
it makes more sense
to think about,
do people have
enough to live on?
But it is more
difficult, because you
have to draw a judgment
about what it is.
So the judgment we've drawn is
what's called the poverty line.
The poverty line was
invented by a civil servant
in the 1960s, Molly Orshansky.
She said, well, what does
it take to live in America?
She said, well, the typical
person spends about a third
of their budget on
food in the 1960s.
So let's cost out the cost of
a nutritionally adequate bundle
of food, multiplied by it three,
and call that the poverty line.
She did that, and that's
still the poverty line.
All we've done is taken that
and updated it by inflation.
Remember, we talked about
the CPI, the inflation rate?
All we've done is taken Molly
Orshansky's poverty line
and updated it by
inflation ever since.
And what do we get?
Well, if you look
at table 21-5, this
shows you the poverty
line in the US today.
It varies by family size,
because you need more resources
with a bigger family.
But not one to one, because
of economies of scale
in the household.
You don't need
twice as much money
to have a household
with two people,
because you still only
need one living unit,
you can share
cookware, you only have
to heat-- heating
for two people isn't
much more expensive than heating
for one person, et cetera.
So there's economies of
scale within the household.
So the poverty line
does not go up--
does not double
with every person,
does not double you go from one
to two-- it less than doubles.
And you could see this scale--
essentially we say that--
this is 2015, so
it's higher now--
but basically says
that one person
with income below $11,170
is living in poverty.
And a family of four,
it's about $24,250.
So it basically says, a
family below $25,000--
a family of four below
$25,000, is living in poverty.
Now is that the right number?
Well-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it different
based on where in the country
you live?
JONATHAN GRUBER: There's a
number of reasons it might not
be the right number.
First of all, it does not differ
based on where in the country
you live.
So if you are-- you guys don't
know because you're sheltered--
but if you right now
tried to take $25,000
and go live in Boston,
there's no way.
I mean, it's just,
like, impossible.
Whereas, in rural
Mississippi, you
can probably do OK on $25,000.
But it doesn't vary by area.
It doesn't vary-- also the
poverty line calculation is all
messed up now, because
when she did it,
food was a third of
people's budgets.
It's now more like 20%
of people's budgets.
It's fallen enormously.
And the other elements that
poor people have to pay,
notably housing and medical
care, have gone up much faster.
The poverty line hasn't
accounted for that.
So in fact, there's
lots of reasons
that this line is problematic.
Nonetheless, it's very
hard to change it.
Indeed, I was in the US
government for 14 months,
and I only went to one
super duper secret meeting.
I went to a lot of meetings with
the president, stuff like that.
But one time, my secretary
said, there's a meeting,
and I can't tell
you what it's about,
and I can't even
tell you where it is.
When the time comes, they will
come get you and bring you
there.
I was like, Jesus,
it's nuclear war.
Like, what the hell?
So they brought me to this
room, we're all in this room.
I'm like, what's going on?
They're like, we need to discuss
revising the poverty line.
I'm like, what?
Well, why is it super secret?
Because the US today distributes
more than a $1 trillion a year
based on the poverty line.
So any changes you make is going
to create winners and losers.
And the losers are
going to be really mad.
And as a result, it's been
incredibly hard to change
the poverty line.
Because for example,
let's say we
change it to recognize the
fact that it should be higher
in New York than Mississippi.
Well, that means New
Yorkers would win
and Mississippians would lose.
Bad news, politically.
New Yorkers would be
happy, Mississippians
would be sad, but because of
diminishing marginal utility,
and the laws of politics,
the guys who are sad
make more noise than
the guys who are happy.
So it's very, very
hard to change this,
despite its
problematic features.
Nonetheless, it's still
a useful benchmark.
It is useful that
it's fixed over time,
because it allows us
to essentially see how
things have evolved over time.
And we can see that
in Figure 21-6.
This shows the poverty
rate over time.
And it shows it for
everybody, that's the red.
It shows it for the
elderly, that's the blue.
For kids, that's the green.
And for non-elderly
adults, that's the yellow.
So what do we see?
We see a couple of things.
First of all, for every
group, poverty fell enormously
during the 1960s.
That's the so-called
war on poverty,
which used a number
of social programs
that lowered poverty
enormously during the 1960s.
For the elderly,
it kept going down.
And the elderly went from
the most impoverished group
in society to the least.
For kids, it bounced back up.
And now kid poverty
rates are nearly as high
as they were back
in the early 1960s.
For the rest of folks, it sort
of went down then flattened.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do you determined
how much wealth a kid has?
JONATHAN GRUBER: It's based
on their family's income.
This is not wealth, it's income.
It's based on
their-- so basically,
when asked does a kid live
in poverty, it's like,
do they live in a household
that's below the poverty line?
So the bottom line is--
think of it as
families with kids,
is another way to
think about this.
The bottom line is,
essentially, poverty
hasn't done a whole lot.
We haven't done a whole lot on
poverty in the last 50 years.
We sort of lowered a lot in
the '60s, and then it's been
bounced up and down, but
it's been pretty flat--
is the result there.
Now, the bottom line is--
now my take, now
I'm going to draw
a judgment-- my take is, along
either of these dimensions,
we don't look so hot.
We're the most unequal
nation the world.
And we have-- still, if
you look at all people,
we have 15% of our people
living below some standard
of absolute deprivation.
Literally saying, we are
accepting that 15% of people
America cannot afford to live.
We are accepting that,
including more than 20% of kids.
So I don't think
we're doing that well.
But in some sense, this is
even the most-- yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: 18 to 64 people,
are those single people?
Because I imagine
kids would fall into--
JONATHAN GRUBER: I mean, that's
like the average of all 18
to 64, including those
that have kids and don't.
So like a child at the age of
64, that would come down more.
It's just the average.
Now, this is a striking set
of facts, but not to my mind
the most striking.
Probably the most striking
fact that probably-- probably
the fact that has seen
the most influence on me
in the last 10 years is
shown in Figure 21-7.
This is a figure put together
in the wake of the Freddie Gray
riots in Baltimore.
You may have heard
about those, that's
when a prisoner was beat to
death in the back of a police
van.
And he was from the
area of Sandtown--
Sandtown, Winchester,
which is a super bad area.
Think The Wire-- if you've
seen The Wire, super bad area
of Baltimore.
About 3 miles away is an
area called Roland Park,
which is a very rich area.
The average life expectancy
in Roland Park is 84 years.
That's above the US average.
That's pretty good.
The average life
expectancy 3 miles away
is 67 years, which
is below North Korea.
And what it was around
World War II in the US.
3 miles, and we got
a 17-year difference
in the average life expectancy.
What's going on?
Well, what you'd expect.
People are way poor.
In Sandtown, the average
income is $107,000--
I'm sorry, Roland
Park is $107,000,
and Sandtown is $24,000--
the average income is
below the poverty line.
In Roland Park, 2.5% of
kids live in poverty.
In Sandtown, it's 55% of kids.
So basically, you have
incredible inequality
in short distances.
To me, this is striking,
because it really
brings home inequality
by putting it
in such sort of close
geographic terms.
So we have a lot of inequality.
There's no question.
And it certainly motivates--
I think it's hard to
look at facts like this,
regardless of your
political stripe,
and not worry, not
at least worry,
and consider the fact that there
may be some role for government
redistribution.
But that's not the
end of the discussion.
This in some sense-- think
of this part of the lecture
as the benefits of
government redistribution.
The benefits of
government redistribution
is we have incredible
inequality, incredible poverty,
all around the country.
Now, we have to
come-- but of course,
in economics, nothing free.
Now we have to come to the
costs of redistribution.
The benefits are clear.
What about the costs?
And so now we have to
talk about the efficiency
costs, or the leakage.
Efficiency costs--
costs of redistribution.
Or in other words, how
big is the leakage?
So going back to Okun, I hope
that these figures inspire
you to think we out to be
putting some money into buckets
and giving it to poor people.
But now the question
is, should we?
What if it all leaks out?
How leaky is the bucket?
And that's what we
need to talk about now.
And basically, leakages in the
bucket come from three sources.
The first and least important
source is administrative costs.
Literally got to pay
someone to carry the bucket.
So if you put a dollar
in and carry the bucket,
he's going to take
some money out
for the right of
carrying the bucket.
That's small, but non-trivial.
Maybe low single digits.
The second source of leakage
is the efficiency costs
of taxation.
If you tax people and
take their money away,
they may work less hard.
Think about the extreme
case, where I'm at to say--
I'm going to go back to
the utilitarian world,
I'm going to tell everyone,
we're going to equalize income.
That means that everyone,
no matter what they make,
example, the same
amount of money.
Why would you work?
I mean, you guys would,
because you're tools.
But why would
regular people work?
They wouldn't.
Because no matter
what you do, you
end up with the same income.
It's 100% tax.
So why would you work?
And that's extreme,
but the point
is, the extreme
example makes the point
that when you tax
people, there's
potential efficiency
costs, in terms
of them earning less income.
The third issue is the
efficiency costs of transfers.
Which is when you
give people money,
and when you give people
money, they may also work less.
So not only might I work
less when you tax me,
I might work less if
you give me money.
Why should I go to work if
you're sending me a check?
So not only would equal
distribution of income
lead me to work less
because I'm being taxed,
leading me to work less
because I'm getting money.
So why should I bother working?
As long as leisure is a
normal good, remember?
I don't want to work.
So if you're just sending me
money, why would I go to work?
So to see this, we
can sort of summarize
this with one example.
So let's go to Figure 21-8,
and I want to walk through--
it's a fairly complicated
example-- let's walk through--
this a simple illustration
of a tax and transfer scheme
of the type we have in America.
We start in this example with an
individual earning $20 an hour.
So the slope of this line
is negative $20 an hour.
This person can work--
and remember, we don't model
work, we model leisure.
I almost made the mistake.
Remember, we don't model
the bad, we model the good.
We don't model labor,
we model leisure.
Let's say that the max leisure
you can take is 2,000 hours.
So you can either take
2,000 hours of leisure
and consume nothing, or
you could take no leisure
and consume 40,000.
Let's say consumption is income,
no savings in this model.
So you earn $20 an hour, you
consume your whole income,
and you can take up to
2,000 hours of leisure.
So your budget constraint is the
dark line running from 40,000
on the y-axis,
2,000 on the x-axis.
Now, let's say that
we're going to put in,
into this budget constraint,
we're going to add two things.
The first is a transfer
program to the poor.
We're worried about poverty.
So we're going to have
a new program, that
says that every American
gets at least $10,000.
Everybody gets $10,000.
But as their income goes up,
we're going to take that away.
So we're going to say, since
we have a transfer program,
the transfer program is
going to be of the form--
the transfer you get
is the max of 0 comma
10,000 minus your income.
That's our transfer program.
So if your income is
0, you get 10,000.
If your income is
10,000, you get zero.
We're just making sure
everybody gets $10,000.
We don't care about people
having more and that,
so we're going take it away.
We're going to say, look, want
to make sure you have $10,000,
but above that, we
don't care about you.
So if you're someone
earning $100,000,
this program's irrelevant.
If you're someone
earning $5,000,
we'll give you another $5,000
to get you up to $10,000.
So that's based on
a transfer program.
This is typically the
way welfare programs
work around the world.
Essentially, they
give you money,
but then they take it
away as you get richer,
to make sure the money is
targeted to the poorest people.
So that's our transfer program.
That's the first thing
it's going to do.
The second thing-- we've
got a transfer program,
but we've got to pay for this.
To pay for this, we
have to have a tax.
Now, let's say we
only want to tax
the rich-- you don't
want to tax the poor,
you want to give
money to the poor.
So let's say our tax program
is of the following form--
anyone making more
than $20,000 per year
pays a 20% tax rate on
the income above $20,000.
So no one's taxed on
the first $20,000.
But on every dollar
above $20,000,
you pay $0.20 to the government.
It's what's called
a marginal tax.
You have a marginal
tax rate of 20%.
What does marginal mean?
It means you only pay
on the next dollar.
So it's a marginal tax
rate of 20% above $20k.
OK, so once you earn $20k,
of $20k, you pay nothing.
Once you've earned $20k,
on every dollar above $20k,
you face a marginal
tax rate of 20%.
You pay $0.20 of every
dollar of the government.
So that is our tax program.
Now, look at the diagram.
Do people understand
how these programs work?
Forgetting the diagram.
Yeah, Manny?
AUDIENCE: In other
countries, is there
any other data to show how this
affects the number of hours
people work?
JONATHAN GRUBER: That's
exactly what we're getting to.
That's our concern, right?
Is that that's my point here,
is that this might lower
how many hours people work.
And let's talk about why.
But the question about the
logistics of these programs,
first.
Let's talk about how it
affect the hours worked.
Let's go to the diagram.
Let's consider several
different people.
Start with person
A. Person A earned--
before this program
was in place,
they would have chosen to be a
high leisure, low consumption
person.
When this program's in place
we tell them, look, person A,
you can get more of both, more
leisure and more consumption,
all you have to do is quit.
Stop working.
You move from
point A to point D.
You get more leisure
and more consumption.
So that naturally happens.
So everyone earning less than
$10,000, immediately quits.
Once again, assuming
leisure is the normal good.
Immediately quits because look,
once you're below $10,000,
it's 100% tax rate.
Why work?
So anyone who would have earned
less than $10,000 doesn't work.
Because you're just going to
give back to the government
anyway, why do you care?
That's person A.
What about person B?
Person B earns
more than $10,000.
But note, their
indifference curve
crosses below the new
budget constraint.
Let me step back, the
new budget constraint
is the red segments plus the
black segment in the middle.
New budget constraint runs
from $32,000 on the y-axis,
it intersects the black line,
the old budget constraint
at $20,000.
It's the old budget constraint
from $20,000 down to $10,000,
and it becomes the
new red segment.
I should mentioned that.
So the budget constraint
is the two red segments
and the black
segment in between.
That's the new
budget constraint.
So let's look at person B. What
happens to person B and why?
What does person B do?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER: Why?
AUDIENCE: Because it's
a higher [INAUDIBLE]..
JONATHAN GRUBER: Right,
crucially, since person
B never crosses the
red line, we know
they must be better off at
point D than at point B.
Because we know that since point
D is above that line, that's
a higher indifference curve
than they're on at point B.
So not only do you cause every
person below $10,000 to quit,
you also cause some people
above $10,000 to quit.
Why?
Well, they give up a
little consumption,
but they get a ton of leisure.
So let's say someone
is at $11,000, $12,000,
like, wait a second,
all my work is only
getting me $1,000 or
$2,000 over quitting.
I might as well quit.
So this welfare program causes
a ton of people to quit.
All the people who were
going to earn very little
quit, and some people who are
going to earn somewhat little
quit.
But that's not all.
Let's look at person
C. Person C used
to work a certain
amount-- you know,
used to work more
than 1,000 hours.
Take less than 1,000
hours of leisure.
Now what happens,
well what happens--
forget the diagram, step back.
If I take someone and
choose a marginal tax rate,
what happens to their
labor supply and why?
What happens to their
leisure and why?
So I take you.
You're working--
let's say you're
taking 800 hours of
leisure, doesn't matter what
the exact number was.
I then come and save
you have a 20% tax rate
on every earnings above $20,000.
How does that
affect your leisure?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Might as
well increase it.
JONATHAN GRUBER: You
would increase it, why?
AUDIENCE: Because
then above $10,000,
I guess you would
get less money,
but I guess maybe less
utility above $10k,
because you're going to
give it to the government?
JONATHAN GRUBER: You
might increase it.
But what might else you do?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The wage
effectively decreases,
so the price of
leisure decreases.
So you take more of it?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Right,
I think that you increase
leisure, that's what he said.
OK, increased leisure,
but what else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Might increase
it just to cover taxes,
so you might work--
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah, what
do we call the two effects?
AUDIENCE: Oh, your
income and substitution.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Exactly,
we have substitution income
effects.
The substitution effect, let's
say your net wage is lower,
your net wage just went from $20
an hour to $16 an hour, right?
So a lower net
wage, you work less,
but the income effect
says, you work more.
Because you're now
effectively poorer.
When you're poorer, you
consume less of everything,
including leisure.
So when you tax my wage, I
might take less leisure, i.e.
work more, through the
substitution effect--
I'm sorry, we tax my wage, I
might take more leisure, i.e.
work less, through the
substitution effect,
because the returns
to work are lower.
But I might take less
leisure, i.e. work more,
because I'm now poorer.
So we don't know
what's going to happen.
But we typically assume
substitution effects dominate.
You can't go wrong in this class
without making that assumption.
We want you remember
the trade-off--
but typically, some
substitute effects dominate.
So we typically think
people will work less.
We think taxing people will
cause them to work less.
But be clear, it's
not obvious it will.
But we typically think
that's the result.
And typically, once again,
when you average men and women,
as we discussed in our labor
supply lecture, overall,
you get an upward slope
in labor supply curve.
That is overall if you
tax people that work less.
So what that does, it lowers
the hours of work for person C.
This is our leaks in the bucket.
We've suddenly massively
reduced the amount, potentially
massively, reduced the amount
people who want to work.
Why do we care?
We care because a Figure 21-9.
What have we done?
We've gone from an initial
point where people initially
had initial supply curve of
S1, and demand curve of D.
And therefore, we're
supplying L1 hours of labor
at a wage, W1.
Now they're producing less--
their supply curve shifts in.
That's created a
deadweight loss.
There is less stuff
being produced,
because people are staying
home rather than working.
And the key point is,
that's not a problem.
Staying home rather than
[INAUDIBLE] is not the problem.
The problem is, they're
staying home only because we've
reduced the price of labor.
We've increased
the price-- we've
reduced the price of
leisure, I'm sorry.
We've reduced the
return to labor,
reduced the price of leisure.
As a result, people
are staying home.
We've distorted their behavior.
We've caused them to
stay home and not work.
We cause them to stay
home and not work,
there's less stuff
for the rest of us.
So it's a deadweight loss.
Efficiency falls.
And that is the efficiency
equity trade-off.
This deadweight
loss is Okun's leak.
That's the leak
it Okun's bucket.
So now we have the trade-off.
On the one hand, we have an
incredibly unequal society,
where a program like this can
really make people better off.
Take money from rich
people who don't need it,
give it to poor people who do.
On the other hand,
in doing so, we're
going to have less
stuff as a society.
We're going to shrink
the size of the pie
in order to redistribute
the slices of the pie.
Is it worth it?
That's where the social
welfare function comes in.
The social welfare
function allows
you to evaluate whether
something like this
is worth it.
Without a social
welfare function,
you can never answer
that question.
You just can't, because there's
one hand and the other hand.
What the social
welfare function does
is give you a mathematical
representation that allows
you to answer that question.
So in section on
Friday, you'll work
through an example of
using a social welfare
function to evaluate a welfare
transfer program like this.
And they'll come back on Monday
and talk more about taxation.